what do you my story is singer Pharrell
Williams had a surprise announcement
during a commencement speech to
graduating charter school students in
Harlem take a look for every member of
the 2019 graduating class is guaranteed
an internship waiting for them you next
summer about that that means a hundred
and fourteen graduating students of the
two charter high schools of the Harlem
Children's Zone Promise Academy will get
internships there all right there
they're into college so this isn't sort
of an extra bonus it's nice to go to
your graduation not only get a diploma
commencement speech but an internship
you can see them getting excited when he
said every one of you again I think they
thought he was gonna say I'm gonna pay
for your college education this is also
very very good yeah it's very good to
know that you're gonna have a guarantee
of a summer job especially with him it's
about providing kids access a
connections in areas where they
otherwise might not get it that's so
important you go for round right let me
talk to you